l'instant nous allons retourner à
chamonix pour le premier ministre est
l'invité de notre journal avec paul amar
edouard balladur prend quelques jours de
vacances mais avec encore du travail et
je dirais de nombreuses sollicitations
renaud fessaguet et alexis marant ont
observé ce matin le premier ministre à
la montagne de mise à caen ce la journée
d'un premier ministre de cohabitation en
vacances commence par du travail dès
9h30 le matin réunion avec le directeur
de cabinet nicolas bazire depuis une
semaine
chamonix est en effet l'autre capitale
politique de la france nous commencerons
chambre et comme si cela ne suffisait
pas edouard balladur doit aussi assumer
son rôle de célébrité locale
de la difficulté d'être reconnu par tout
le monde enfin presque tout le monde le
premier ministre
puis c'est l'heure de la promenade
aujourd'hui c'est pour faire plaisir aux
journalistes mais d'habitude le premier
ministre ne manque jamais d'escaladé
l'un des sommets de la vallée le col de
balme ou le brévent terrible aujourd'hui
c'était un jour aller manger des filles
de ben ali avec ses allées jusqu'à la
croix de fer 3 à 4 heures par jour par
tous les temps d'un pas vif et alerte
sur tous les sentiers environnants son
chalet de chamonix pour edouard balladur
la marche en montagne est le dernier
refuge lorsque les vacances sont
rattrapés par la politique elle est même
le seul moment où il peut vraiment
échapper à l'emprise du microcosme